today we are going to be talking about
the tournament that's going on right now
actually just finished in Europe and in
that tournament the world champion who
is it
anybody that's right magnus carlsen the
world champion won the tournament
although you had a lot of stiff
competition so I want to take a look at
one of his games where he attacked his
opponent and I hope that you guys will
help me find some of his really good
attacking moves here he's actually
playing against one of the best players
in the world his posters actually up
right behind you who's he playing that's
right
are you our onion fan I could I could
tell by the way you pronounced his name
that you were a fan because you
pronounced it very well so here we go
unfortunately you might not like this
game so much so cover your eyes but it
is Magnus so he's not it's not like he's
losing me just anybody he's losing to
the world champion but I don't think
that would happened to the line he's
gonna win against them every time so in
this position what do you guys think
Magnus did for for white in this
position what move might you consider
playing at all right so what would you
do here is why it looks like all your
pieces are really in good shape so any
way that you can increase the attack
here yes
that's a really interesting idea play
Knight takes d5 and then after Knight
takes d5 we teach d5 it looks like you
picked up a pond but what potential
ideas does black have here no black
black has some ideas here in fact in
fact this positions get pretty
interesting yeah you could move the
Queen to e6 but note that now weight is
up a pond so Magnus might think that
being the world champion you can win and
gave up a pond and just trade Queens or
you might just move back the Queen and
I'll try to win that way but either way
it will be a pretty good situation for
Wyatt
yeah but UK is a really interesting move
because now you're attacking this rook
and you're attacking this Queen what
does have an interesting counter here
though does anybody see what white might
play here pin and win and then it's
going to get really messy yes okay
anybody see a pin here that way you can
take advantage of yes where takes g6 is
an interesting move because notice this
pawn can capture why not it's a pin
right that's a really important pattern
to remember right but it's actually not
the end of the story here suppose black
does play something like King to h7 here
now how many of whites pieces are in
take care are or could be captured
a lot how many actually three right I
can take this rock I can take this Queen
I can take this rock so I don't think
white can protect against all that
probably the best try yeah what's the
fourth one three three is enough oh
you're thinking maybe that I'm attacking
this twice so I'm attacking with the
pawn and the King so Mac has decided
that instead of going for that variation
right away why not go for the same
variation idea but put more pressure
first on black so how do magnets put
even more pressure on the latter Audion
here so his pieces are all in good shape
but he used another thing yes not 96
it's a fantastic idea but it's not what
he played here he did that a little bit
later how do you make how do you hit g6
with another thing so Knight takes g6 is
possible how do you put another point on
g6 notice notice that Magnus has
recently played to move h4 why do you
think he wants to play h4 yes
and he can make an attacking move after
playing eight four yes that's in your
Essen nope yeah
he can play h5 here that's a fantastic
move and now with h5 you're threatening
to take on g6 and then this pawn is
going to be removed and wait when they
start taking on d5 it's going to be a
check so this move very strong and that
goes to show when you're attacking your
opponent with all your pieces sometimes
what do you need to break open the
position even more you need to use not
your pieces but your what that's right
right so sometimes you use your pawns to
crack open files and diagonals to hurt
your opponent and that's exactly what
happened here because after King g7 now
after takes twice on g6 what's the weak
point in this position that Magnus is
going to go after yeah excellent very
good but especially g6 because that's
already attacked once by the knight and
it's not protected by any pawns notice
also that even the e6 square could
become a problem later
so magnets now played Knight takes d5
and now after 95 qui vive he had a very
a particular idea in mind here so black
played Bishop takes g3 take taking a
pawn off here with the idea that if pawn
takes g3 black will just play what so
it's a discovered attack rook takes
Queen exactly so what did magnets do
instead a pawn takes g3 here now you
played an excellent move let's see if
you guys can find Magnus's excellent
move here please like the world champion
you played a very good move here now
usually when you're attacking usually
you like to keep your pawns but
when you're attacking losing a pond can
sometimes have a silver lining that it
can open up a line of attack and that's
what happens here that losing this pawn
on g3 actually ends up being a positive
for Magnus Carlsen
that's right upon is only worth one
point so sometimes you can get away with
giving them up they're not well they're
basically Razak revising pawn they're
not quite just for sacrificing sometimes
when you're attacking sometimes when
attacking it feels that way but remember
if you don't attack checkmate your
opponent's king in the middle game how
do you win the game what's what's your
other way to win the game if you don't
in Panay and chess is attack your
opponent's king in the middle game and
checkmate them what's plan B yeah and
how do you usually do that not quite
with pawns kind of exactly plan B is
usually you promote a pawn you make a
queen and you checkmate them in the
endgame but what does that mean what's
very important to be ahead on if you're
planning to win on the endgame you need
to be ahead in pawns right so they
aren't just for sacrificing but let's
get back to this position weight to move
what would you do so your Queens and
take yeah
so you've gotta move your queen
but where's a good square to move that
Queen to yes hmm we need for the thing
is if we're attacking do we want to
trade Queens no you don't want to trade
Queens because then we won't be able to
attack that easily right and actually in
this position we're going down in pawns
so we're well we're going even in pawns
we're just going to all probably take
each other's ponds and it'll be kind of
even so and in black probably actually
adds even better moves there so maybe
I'm looking at Bishop takes up to here
but but in any case Bishop takes up to
just snatching upon first and then after
King f2 we have some other options which
might make this some very dangerous for
you but the very least we can just take
here as I pointed out in the last
variation so instead of Queenie for what
else what else can we do to keep the
attack line yes what other good moves
are there guys yeah
excellent
queen g2 is the best move in the
position because now when this bishop
goes away
what is boy targeting he's targeting
this pawn once again right and so the
bishop must go back to d6 otherwise
we'll play Queen takes g6 and we're
going to be winning
so after Bishop d6 Magnus lead 94 and
then after we're cafe what do you think
he played here no I want you to think so
now we played a key move to target this
weakness right here how do you target
that weakness right there on g6 which
all began with this really nice idea of
h5 so that's what sometimes at the baton
chest
it's about attacking a piece until your
opponent can't defend it anymore the
better you get the more harder it's
going to be to just attack a piece your
opponent doesn't see it you take it
obviously that happens a lot but the
better you get they're going to see it
sometimes if you play clever enough even
if you even if they see it they can't do
anything about it yes excellent
fantastic idea 95 that is what Magnus
Carlsen played now the beautiful thing
about this move is that now we're trying
to play what yes
no white white is our name to play what
yes in the back
you got it Queen takes what yeah
yep you got it Queen take exactly Queen
take g6 is a brutal threat
we're also threatening to take this nut
this work off so black thought it was
necessary as you pointed out in the
front row to play Bishop takes e5 but
now white anyway is able to insert a
little in between move yes well we don't
quite have checked me but we've got a
good move yes exactly so we play Queen
takes g6 they call this in a white what
do they call this one instead of taking
this back on e5 right away we start with
the move Queen takes g6 does anybody
know what that's called anybody you know
that has a special name in jazz yeah no
yes no it's called an in-between move
and is a very important chest tactic so
you take my Queen and you think I'm just
going to take your Queen back but
instead I check you and I went another
piece so Queen takes g6 and now after
Queen takes 8 6 finally magnets took
back 185 because if you plays rook to
you 6 now that's not so great because
the bishop can come back to defend so
finally he took this off but meanwhile
look at this King does it have any
defense no it's just got no one no pawns
in front of it
so my the big Levon Aronian friend in
the back is looking very sad because
that King is not in good shape and so
now a nice move by Magnus he's bringing
another rook into the attack what do I
call this anybody listen to any my
commentary you would know this so
basically the work is going to c4 and
then the idea is that we're going to f4
and then we have one more piece in the
party right invite everybody at a party
you want all of the pieces participating
in the attack this specific way of
getting another piece into the attack is
called no it's called a Rover Rover
stands for rook up and over
so we're trying to get our rook from
seaboard f4 because something is hard to
get the rooks into the attack they can
be a little bit clumsy or they are the
second most powerful piece but they're
particularly proficient in end games
in middle games sometimes it's tough to
get the work in right so now we reach
this position and we do get the work at
f4 check and now work to e6 check and
black tries to climb out of the
situation by getting some trades in now
Magnus please look for check and this is
where it gets really interesting what
would you do now Black's playing team da
looks like he's running away now White
has a really good sequence of moves what
can we do now hamton
this might take you a minute to figure
out all the permutations here all the
different possibilities remember
whenever you're playing chess at a high
level you guys are in the advanced class
here so I know a lot of you are playing
stronger and stronger every day
you need to look at all of your
opponent's different responses
especially with captures and Jack's
yes what do you think that's not the
best move because then after Queen takes
h8 you don't have a clear continuation
so instead of Queen h8 anything else yes
okay
the Queen h4 is also intact by the rook
so there is a way is there a way to
interfere with the connection here
between this Queen and this rock anybody
see a way where we might be able to
interfere with that because this idea of
Queen takes h8 is a good one just
doesn't work at the moment because the
Queen could just capture so how can we
interfere with that idea yes
and then you want to move this work here
where do you want to move it to up like
that or like that well if we go up one
it's not a force you move so our
opponent will just take here on h6 right
so instead no don't lose your queen yes
instead write instead soul magnets
instead would have played before check
that's interfering between this Queen
and this rook so now if the King runs
away now your move works all of a sudden
right queen takes that's an excellent
question that is a very good question
now what if LaVon were to play queen
takes rook with the idea that after pawn
takes Queen now who's winning black
would be winning because after pawn
takes Queen rook takes Queen backs up
what black would be upper rook but do
you think Magnus would allow that or
would he find a better move here but
what is it what is it it's another one
of those in-between moves which come up
so much especially at the Grandmaster
level that for the for the amateur level
and the youth chess level the most
important tactics tend to be double
attack pins forks forks and double
attack is the same thing but at the
Grandmaster level in between moves is
the most important tactic no good
question no the most common not the best
the more the one that comes up the most
in games yes
Queen g5 beautiful move Queen g5 check
and now notice that there's no way for
us to use the Queen to block this
effectively and now when the King moves
now we take the Queen and now we've got
a queen verse or up do you think magnus
carlsen can win that yes the world
champion can win that how many people
here can win that say yes we can all win
with the Queen versus the rook right
even if we're playing Magnus Carlsen
right
yes what what Queen g7 if it's our move
next we would play it's not our move but
the problem is that this Queen and this
point are so powerful that we could be
even a Levon Aronian or magnus carlsen
in this position is Wyatt right as long
as you don't hang anything you would win
the game
and so instead instead of King d8 in the
game actually it ended like this instead
we're actually I think of on resigned at
some point around here I was playing
around with it to show some cool
variations but this this is another way
for the game to end if the King just
goes to d7 now Queen e6 check King d8
and work d4 and this is actually almost
a checkmate they'd be forced to take
that work on D forearm and again we
would be left with a queen and upon
verse this rock an easy win for white
okay
exactly
ten points versus five easy went very
good okay any other questions or you
guys are ready to play some awesome
chess some world champion style chess
today in the tournament right all right
so castle and try to attack your
opponent's Kings I wish you all good
luck